systems elsewhere and she's coming do
you think she actually respects you can
we ask the girl maybe I'm actually
curious to get your take on this if
you're dating a guy let's just say words
we're dating a guy and he says baby I
love you you're everything I ever wanted
in the girl like you're perfect your
body your smile the way you treat me
everything about you is perfect but if
you want to go out and [ __ ] other guys
I'm totally cool with it how would you
take that but this this is an
interesting question I'm actually okay
with with your belief system it's like
teach their own it's not the norm yeah
so it's probably weird to hear but if
you know teach their own
everyone have their own leaves about oh
so we talking about me personally
you know what I mean it's a bit cuckold
yeah you could you you can just you can
describe to whatever yeah I'm curious
what you're gonna say go ahead uh it's
an interesting question to ask me right
now
um I
I've always really valued the idea of
monogamy
um and when I was like 19 I fell in love
with someone
uh and it was not a healthy relationship
was pretty toxic but I really love the
idea that we were each other's persons
so I really believe in that I believe
that I have a person out there who I'm
gonna be a team with right and I believe
in the masculine and The Feminine
Dynamic right I do believe in that
um I've considered the idea of polyamory
before right
um just based on the fact that when I
met this person I thought I would never
connect anyone as deeply as I could
connect to him right right and that was
more spiritually emotionally that sort
of thing um and since then I've met a
lot of people that I've connected
emotionally and spiritually to and it's
not always been sexual sometimes that's
just friendships and that sort of thing
but I realized that the depth of
connection I can have with people isn't
really limited to one person I still
have an idea that I believe I have my
person
um but I I think I could entertain the
idea of an open relationship
um would you prefer it
I this is where I'm at right now I
actually don't know you don't know I
don't know it's still something I'm
trying to figure out because I do like I
said I I value the idea of um like I
want a family I want to have you know I
want to be a mom I want to have a kid I
want to have a very strong family
Dynamic that's kind of something I see
for myself
um
um and I don't know if an open
relationship would necessarily be
conducive to that based based on what
Society kind of says right but I also
believe that a child can be raised in a
happy environment regardless of the
parameters of the relationship as long
as they're loved forget what society
says I think if you meet a man yeah
right and he loves you and you love him
he's going to not generally generally
he's not going to want to let you you're
not going to want to loan your vagina
out yeah and this is why I don't know if
I'm polarized because because I don't
like the idea of someone I'm with
sleeping with other people I'd want to
be that you know we choose each other
right and we commit to each other and
then we would grow and build whatever
from there
um I I kind of like the this is I don't
know it doesn't get in TMI but I like
the idea of bringing someone else into
the relationship
whatever guys can can probably can the
mother of your child loan her vagina at
somebody else I don't have any children
but I would predict no for me guys
absolutely not no chance
you may learn your vagina out it's not
it's not transaction it may is what if
she gets pregnant
what if she gets pregnant unique
individual
you are a unique individual yeah I know
I [ __ ] I love it it's great TV it's
great TV but I'm just saying like I
would you be okay with the mother of
your child
in a polyamorous relationship with you
yes what if she gets pregnant with
another man's house
if she has consented like then like
would you raise the child I I I I was
raised by a stepfather so you would
raise the child yes I was I I was like
my the the the the the man the the male
that raised me my Alpha it was not my
biological father
Society does need you know men to raise
a women's kids in certain circumstances
and and this is this so one I saw
something like it but I think it was a
post or something about a lawyer who was
like a divorce lawyer and he was saying
to this couple that you know what if my
kids have to grow up with you know two
sets of parents and they said well a kid
can never have enough people to love
them right there's always more people
that can love a child and help them grow
right kids are raised by a village right
and the more people that love them but
they do need a biological but the
problem is not necessarily not
necessarily they need a strong masculine
figure yes and that can manifest it I
will say that one problem is that like
the I can't remember the stat off the
top of my head I'd look it up but my
laptop died they took it
but it's like the when somebody is a
single parent the most likely person
that is going to sexually abuse them as
someone they bring into the house in a
relationship and so you're putting your
kid at risk and I know everyone thinks I
know everyone thinks like oh it wouldn't
happen if me like I would vet them
better but you just never know everybody
so then I would bring it back to saying
that's probably the exception and that's
the biggest reason in terms of that
context because I and I think if we go
back to like properly vetting someone
and probably making proper choices right
you have to consider the kids right and
that's that's that's you know if you do
that then you're probably not I agree
with you I do think it's the exception
not the rule I don't think that every
single step parent is abusing the child
but the the point the but the point is
you're still putting that kid at risk
for abuse you're putting them at risk
they're more likely to run away from
home they're more likely to
um to be on the streets yeah to be on
drug like it's like every every city
mental health issues every statistical
advantage that you could put a kid at
you're putting them at in a single
parent home right and to be in jail
as much as you like but you're still
just throwing random numbers that don't
actually have anything okay okay I can
even tell you like just anecdotally and
like so just from talking to people day
to day like I I have nine siblings same
two parents we've adopted three and like
when I talk to people that come from
single parent homes about like my
family's Traditions every year like I've
never seen like such like like they want
that so bad it's really sad like they've
never experienced like no I'm sorry
sorry I'm laughing at something else
um no it's it's sad though like they've
never experienced like Christmas with
both parents together like and then all
the traditions we do like we do pictures
with Santa every year we do like an
Easter egg hunt like like family's
really big and I I just see like the
loss that's someone's out when they
didn't get to grow up with two parents
and I just wouldn't wish that upon
anyone but I think I think again that
comes down to two parents yes but also
having adults that love you right and
adults that are a team that can raise
you right because that's a big family
and you have Traditions but you can have
traditions and lots of different family
Dynamics right in the polyamorous room
right one team comes together to raise a
kid you can still build Traditions well
it's just a bit of a different Dynamic
but I think I think it's better like we
kind of did had a a team raise us
because like we had we had help and we
also had like relatives that stepped in
my grandma's like I could name you a
long list of people that helped and
stepped in but I think it's better when
it's like in the family and it's all
what's the difference between a
community that you build in a community
that's biological like I would say I
would say it's it's like more vetted and
so like you're happy because you're
going around people that have known each
other for years for a year like and well
more vetted that like because family
members are um no but family members are
they they can be that person who
sexually abuses you know it is possible
because that's what happened right
that's not not gonna happen you're
correct but I would say that it's easier
to like I put it
like everyone knows who the weird uncle
is everyone everyone knows exactly rude
uncle is in the family and you keep your
kids away from the weird uncle and I'm
not saying it doesn't happen but I
just anecdotally would guess that it
happens at a much lower rate when it's
family than when it's random people that
you've met I don't know if you'd be able
to can I just say because I want to go
back to what something that you said
because I said that children need two
biological parents and you said that
they don't yeah right
how do you reconcile that a child who
was born of two people
doesn't need those two people
how do you reconcile like how how do you
say they don't need that if that if
that's how they came into the world
so so my entire existence I was raised
by someone who wasn't my biological
parent and he's my father and he's one
would you raise my was your mother there
your biological mother my biological
mother was there yes and I was raised by
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible